non pardon je sens que vous qu'il faille
non se faire vacciner j'en sais rien je
suis pas médecin j'ai pas de recul c'est
pas ça le sujet le principe ce que non
si riche pas d'accord avec vous c'est
pas chacun fait ce qu'il veut ça serait
à vivre non le principe d'une société de
vivre en société c'est que justement pas
d'achat parce que sinon moi j'adore
conduire à 200 sur autoroute je peux le
faire ces
séries la cseries sinon chacun sait
d'exemple plus précis n'ont pas les vues
sur une folie sur une île déserte j'ai
voulu faire ce qu'on voulait on vers une
société guillaume mais a le droit de
donner son avis et dire voilà moi je me
suis fait vacciner je pense que c'est
bien après engueuler les gens les faire
culpabiliser en tyrie quand il dit il
commence à me saouler dire qu'en
patrimoine dit il commence à nous
saouler vous lire entre les lignes ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire en fait moi
et c'est ce qu'on m'a dit moi tout l'été
quand je le faisais pas vacciner ça veut
dire c'est à cause de toi si on porte
des masses c'est à cause de toi si on
est confiné tu sais ça veut dire qu'au
gouvernement a décidé que tu vis dans
une société où tu a élu un gouvernement
qui a décidé que il faut
chez moi je t'aime beaucoup merci à
peine arrivé blessé et je
vois comparaison n'est pas raison
mathieu pour deux raisons précises
d'abord ça que j'ai pris de la raison
n'est pas là comme la vaccination n'est
pas obligatoire mais rouler à 265 m y
pala interdit donc ça si tu sais danser
sur le gâteau avait quasiment vu passer
dans un premier temps a dit aux gens
quelque chose les jeunes qui trompe avec
s'ils ne sont pas hors la loi voilà
exactement
il ya des gens qui sont pas vaccinés
mathieu qui porte le masque qui respecte
cette barrière qui font très très
attention qui sont scrupuleusement
attentif à ne pas se faire contaminer et
à ne pas contaminer il ya des gens qui
sont vaccinés oui tu sais qu'on peut
l'attraper on peut le donner ils disent
les gestes verts s'assure plus rien je
ne porte plus le masque je suis vacciné
il ya des gens matinée qui sont plus
dangereux que de nom bac cinéma
ces deux exceptions à des exceptions une
règle chacun j'entends le
individuellement ya des gens sérieux qui
ne sont pas vaccinés il ya des gens pas
sérieux qui sont vaccinés et vice et
versa et c'est pour ça qu'il est de
mauvais ton à mon avis de données je
dirais une forme de parole et
socialisante dédie à tous les non
vaccinés sont des irresponsables ça
n'est pas vrai qu'il faut arrêter de les
culpabiliser il ya pas les bons français
vaccinés d'un côté et les mauvais c'est
pour les histori ces deux